just like the Simpsons millions of
people are waiting for the total solar
eclipse to begin the moon will move
between the Sun and the earth on Monday
it'll block out sunlight and create a
shadow that will move from coast to
coast across the US for the first time
in 99 years the Eclipse starts around
1:00 Eastern 10 a.m. Pacific
it'll move east through a 70 mile wide
path 14 states from Oregon to South
Carolina will witness the total eclipse
before it ends around 3 p.m. in the east
and noon in the West CBS news science
and futurist contributor Michio Kaku is
a physics professor at the City
University of New York and he is just
mildly excited I told people kidding
it's pretty good about the about the
Eclipse right yeah first of all this
should be on everyone's bucket list yeah
okay you just got to see it now I'm a
physicist and this is about as close as
a scientist can get to a spiritual
experience you feel like you're at one
with the universe cosmic forces right
there in your sunglasses I just it was
incredible Lonnie Quinn said that for
him it's like Christmas morning that
he's coming in on his day off because he
wants to see it he is that excited you
said that it's on your bucket list and
so for those of us who may not be as
excited as you are there may be some
people like that what should we be
looking for what what should we
how do we wrap our brains around what is
actually happening here well we are
witnessing a cosmic coincidence the Sun
is 400 times farther away than the moon
but it's also 400 times bigger than the
moon and the two numbers cancel exactly
and that's why the moon is going to go
right in front of the Sun this is a
cosmic coincidence and here we are to
witness something like that in your own
backyard yeah what has science learned
from these total eclipses well first of
all the fact that astronomers worked out
the mechanics of an eclipse 2,000 years
ago was the beginning of astronomy
that's where astronomy began to
understand why we have eclipses why the
moon goes in front of the Sun now we
want to know about the atmosphere the
corona it is too hot for its own good
it's about a million
ease the atmosphere of this Sun but the
surface of the Sun is only ten thousand
degrees you know there's a nobel prize
waiting for someone who could figure out
why the atmosphere is much hotter than
the surface of the Sun which then it was
responsible for solar flares gigantic
solar flares that one day could knock
out our satellites and power stations so
this is very practical we have to
understand the atmosphere to understand
these giant coronal mass discharges
which could influence our saddle and I
see you already have your sunglasses
it's all set to go for people to know
that you really cannot look at it
directly in that in Europe you may
suffer retinal damage so get your
sunglasses that are ISO certified and
then you can watch it and for 2 minutes
and 40 seconds you'll commune with the
universe I do think that's exciting I
can't wait to talk to you after it
mm-hmm and during yeah Michio Kaku thank
you very much CBS News will bring you
special reports on the total solar
eclipse you can watch starting Monday at
1:00 Eastern noon central right here on
CBS because even if you're not in the
path of totality you'll still see you'll
still see something that's right and you
went into continental US they'll see a
partial eclipse or a total eclipse I
will be watching thank you very much